simplifica la expresión usando
exponentes racionales y tenemos la raíz
cúbica de todo esto lo cual es
equivalente por definición a 64 x a la
sexta por b cúbica por sea la novena
todo esto elevado a la un tercio
estas son iguales como hemos dicho por
definición y si tenemos el producto de
estas cosas que está elevado al un
tercio eso es lo mismo que elevar cada
una de estas cosas a un tercio y después
realizar la multiplicación así es que
esto es lo mismo que 64 elevado a la
potencia un tercio por a la sexta
elevado a la potencia un tercio por b al
cubo elevado a la potencia un tercio y
finalmente por pse a la novena elevado a
la potencia un tercio y esto ya lo hemos
visto varias veces en vídeos anteriores
ahora 64 al un tercio esto es igual a 4
pero si no es evidente para ti siempre
puede ser una facturación de primos esto
al ser igual a 4 por si acaso no es
obvio para ti que 4 al cubo es 64
entonces te sugiero que hagas una
factorización con números primos
vamos a hacer lo vamos a recordar cómo
se hace la factorización por números
primos entonces 64 es igual a 2 por 32
32 es 2 por 16 16 62 por 88 es dos por
cuatro
finalmente cuatro es dos por dos tenemos
entonces 64 es 2 que se multiplica
asimismo seis veces dos a lasexta aquí
tenemos dos por dos por dos por dos por
dos por 22 a la sexta o dos por dos
multiplicado por sí mismo tres veces dos
por dos es cuatro así es que estamos
multiplicando cuatro por sí mismo tres
veces cuatro al cubo entonces si no
resulta evidente para ti que la raíz
cúbica 64 es 4 siempre puede ser la
factorización como lo hicimos aquí y
darte cuenta que 64 es 2 elevado la
sexta potencia o 4 elevado al cubo
te dejo entonces que pienses sobre eso
entonces si este de aquí es 4 elevado al
cubo y eso lo estamos elevando al a un
tercio eso es exactamente lo mismo mejor
déjame escribirlo aquí abajo para que se
vea más interesante entonces tenemos que
64 es 4 al cubo lo cual estamos elevando
al a un tercio así que esto sería 4
por tres a la un tercio vamos a ponerlo
aquí abajo este término aquí es cuatro
por tres hay un tercio que es cuatro
elevado a la tres tercios cuatro al cubo
y eso a la un tercio y luego aquí
tenemos a la sexta y eso elevado a la un
tercio a la sexta elevado a un tercio ha
elevado a la seis por un tercio o ha
elevado a la potencia seis tercios y
luego tenemos b al cubo elevado a la un
tercio hacemos lo mismo que hemos estado
haciendo multiplicamos los ponentes esto
es b a la tres por un tercio que es b
elevado a la potencia tres tercios y
luego tenemos se elevado a la novena
potencia y es elevado a la potencia un
tercio eso hacer se elevado a la
potencia nueve tercios
ahora simplificando los exponentes este
primer término de aquí cuatro elevado a
tres tercios es 4 elevado la 1 o
simplemente 4 ha elevado a la potencia
seis tercios es ha elevado a la 2 o a
cuadrada luego tenemos velo a la
potencia tres tercios que es b elevado a
la 1 o simplemente b y finalmente
tenemos elevado a la potencia nueve
tercios que se elevado a la 3
se ubican y así hemos concluido